So we've finally gone through the first step
of the central dogma, transcription, and we have
our MRNA. So the second step of the
central dogma is to turn that MRNA into protein
using a process called translation. Translation relies heavily
on the molecular machinery. On a component known
as a ribosome. Ribosomes are the main driver
of translation. Ribosomes are actually able to read an
MRNA sequence by taking it in at one end and reading the MRNA sequence
all the way through to the other end. And as it does this, it takes those 20
amino acids And reads the code determining which
amino acid belongs in a particular position. Now
one of the most exciting puzzles of the 20th century, was to figure out how this
code worked? I mean how is that this genetic code
that these 4 letters and in what combination is that the
[UNKNOWN]
can read this. And add the right amino
acid. Was it one base, one letter, per amino
acid? If true, that would only give us
four possible combinations: an A, a G, a C,
or a U, and we know that we have at least 20 amino acids to get to.
If it's two bases per amino acid Then
that would only be sixteen possible combinations. Things like
AG, AC, AU, GC, GA, GU, and so forth and so on. Only sixteen combinations
but still 20 amino acids. So just extending
that logic a little further, what's the minimum
number of bases needed To have enough combinations
to code for at least 20 amino acids.
Go ahead and put the number that you think is best in this text box here.